justin trudeau to take the floor
my friends president zielenski vladimir
mustafa agga leader of the crimean tatar
people partners allies i'm joining you
today from toronto with the german
chancellor my friend olaf schultz
last year when canada participated in
the first crimea platform summit no one
yet knew that vladimir putin would
launch a full-scale unprovoked invasion
of the rest of ukraine
today on the eve of ukraine's
independence day we're here to reaffirm
our steadfast support for the full
restoration of your independence
territorial integrity
and sovereignty we're here to remind the
world that within ukraine's
internationally recognized borders
there is crimea
crimea is a part of ukraine not a part
of russia
in fact we can't forget that putin's
invasion of ukraine really started in
2014 with the attempted annexation and
illegal occupation of crimea and the
city of sevastopol
the ukrainian people have the right to
defend themselves including in crimea so
canada will continue to be there to
support you and we know that our allies
like germany will continue to do the
same
canada
democracy
russia invaded ukraine
they attacked the basic principles and
right this is um unacceptable
back in may i was in
ukraine and
i
saw all the brutality war
waged by voldemort putin
1
750 individuals and entities from russia
ukraine and belarus and today we're
announcing new sanctions on 62
additional individuals and one defense
sector entity that is complicit in
russia's war in ukraine
we should all be deeply concerned about
the consequences of russia's war both in
ukraine and around the world this
includes inflation as well as economic
energy and food in security
through the imf we recently provide 450
million dollars in loans to ukraine to
support the purchase of necessary
heating fuel before winter we've now
dispersed the complete 1.95
billion dollars in loans committed this
year
for food security canada proposed an
initiative with the food and agriculture
organization of the united nations and
we're investing 52 million dollars to
help address grain storage shortages in
ukraine
i want to repeat yet again that there
are no sanctions on food when the
russian regime blames sanctions for the
food crisis around the world they're
engaging in disinformation
we need to continue fighting russian
disinformation that's why canada will
create a dedicated team to help increase
our capacity to monitor and detect
russian and other state-sponsored
disinformation with this initiative we
will enable deeper deeper international
collaboration including through the g7
rapid response mechanism canada will
also provide additional support to
ukraine's security sector institutions
through two different projects the first
will support the national police of
ukraine and ukraine's state emergency
services including with the provision of
essential equipment and supplies and the
second is focused on providing technical
advice and support to ukraine's ministry
of defence
thank you for participation in this
and
the opportunity to participate in this
um
thank you your excellency and naturally
the floor now goes to the federal
chancellor of germany olive schultz sir
please
president zelensky justin dear
colleagues and friends of ukraine
thank you very much for the invitation
to this year's crimea platform summit
eight years after russia's illegal
annexation of crimea and six months
after the beginning of russia's latest
blatant war of aggression it is more
than timely to come together with
partners in this important forum today
on the day we commemorate the victims of
stalinism and fascism we make once again
clear that the international community
will never accept russia's illegal
imperialist annexation of ukraine
territory
russian
unprovoked and unjustified war of
aggression
against ukraine has been met with a
courageous defense by the ukrainian
people to them i pay my utmost respect
their resolve and bravery are admired at
all over the world
they reject a world
where might makes right where great
powers can just swallow up smaller
states if they like
this summoned demonstrates that today
ukraine's partners are more united than
ever
i can assure you today as an elmo when i
met with my fellow leaders of the g7
germany stands firmly by the site of
ukraine for as long as ukraine needs our
support
we will uphold our unprecedented
sanctions together with partners
we will support ukraine financially
we will continue to supply weapons
we have put on track a new package
including another
modern air defense systems rocket
launchers and tons of ammunition
anti-drone devices
and armed recovery vehicles
our hospitals will continue to treat
bounded ukrainians our borders our
schools and our labor market will remain
open to all who must flee russia's
terror
what is equally important together with
our partners and allies we have
intensified our outreach to third
countries to further strengthen the
international support of ukraine
under the german g7 presidency argentina
senegal south africa india and indonesia
were invited to the elma summit as
partner countries and were closely
involved in our discussions on the
repercussions of the russian war of
aggression
be it wire g7 the eu the united nations
or the crimea platform we will continue
our international outreach and underline
the global dimension of this conflict
we condemn russia's attempts to
forcefully integrate parts of ukrainian
territory
our message is clear
any sham referenda or other attempts to
alter the status of parts of ukraine
territory will never be recognized
and that such such steps preclude any
negotiation approaches
it is russia with its war of aggression
that is responsible for worsening food
security with grave implications for
people worldwide as a reaction to this
crisis
at this year's summit in alma dg7
provided an additional 4.5 billion us
dollar support for global food security
we welcome the recent united nations
agreement on grain exports by our
maritime safe corridors
as european union we have facilitated
grain exports via land and rivers thus
exporting over 8 million tons of
ukrainian grain between april and early
august through our solidarity lanes
we also see that storage capacities in
ukraine are still under pressure
to address this canada germany and japan
are financing with other
with over 60 million us dollars a new
program of the food and agricultural
organization
this program will in coordination with
the ukrainian government support small
and medium-sized farms with temporary
and fixed storage solutions for grain
and oil seats
in addition
the international community also has to
engage actively in the long-term
reconstruction of ukraine
bearing in mind the size of the
challenge we need to accelerate the work
that we started in lugano
in support of this process
my capacity as president of the g7 and
together with the european commission i
will host an international high level
expert conference for reconstruction in
berlin in october
we want to bring in international
expertise as early as possible and take
forward the proposals that are already
on the table
ladies and gentlemen i'm certain ukraine
will overcome the dark shadow of war
because it is
strong brave and united in its fight for
independence and sovereignty
and because it has friends in europe and
all over the world
i wish my ukrainian colleagues and
friends a safe celebration of their
national independence day tomorrow
thank you
thank you mr chancellor and the next
speaker is the prime minister of the
united kingdom his excellency mr boris
johnson
i want to congratulate
president vladimir
for bringing us together and for
focusing our attention on russia's
illegal annexation of crimea
because that land grab in 2014 was the
direct precursor of today's war
and we should have the humility to
acknowledge
not everybody realized the sheer
enormity of what was happening at the
time
all of our countries however reacted
with strength and unity
after putin escalated his onslaught
against ukraine on the 24th of february
this year
but the first
this tragedy
and exactly eight years earlier almost
uh to the day when russian forces began
fanning out across crimea
and taking control of a peninsula which
constitutes ten thousand square miles of
sovereign ukrainian territory
stroke putin
forcibly next the territory
the european country
and forcibly
redrew
a european frontier
for the first time
since 1945.
he ignored the fact that russia itself
had repeatedly recognized crimea as
being part of ukraine
and he broke so many international
agreements that i can't list them all
but they include article two of the
united nations charter the helsinki
final act
and the russia ukraine treaty of
friendship
and ever since the annexation the people
of crimea have endured a brutal and
systematic campaign of human rights
abuses by the russian authorities
including
the persecution of the tartars
arbitrary arrests with a tenfold
increase in detentions last year
and the restriction of land ownership to
russian citizens
once he grabbed crimea putin deployed
more and more russian forces in the
peninsula turning the territory
into an armed camp
from which to threaten
the rest of ukraine
and so
crimea duly became the launch pad for
the invasion on the 24th of february or
one of the launch pads
and
i'm afraid that all this has even
greater salience today
because putin
is planning to do
to other parts of ukraine
indeed all of ukraine at what he has
done
to crimea
and he is preparing more annexations and
more sham
referendums
so it has never been more important for
us all to stand together
in defense of the foundational principle
of international law
which is that no territory no country
can acquire territory
or change borders
by force of arms
and so it follows that we will never
recognize russia's annexation of crimea
or any other ukrainian territory
in the face of putin's assault
we must continue to give our ukrainian
friends
all the military humanitarian
economic
and diplomatic support
that they need until russia
ends
this hideous war
and withdraws its forces
from the entirety of ukraine
thank you all very much
you prime minister
our next speaker is his excellency mr
emmanuel macron president of france
mr president ladies and gentlemen
the heads of states and governments
ministers ambassadors dear friends
it's been
eight years
since uh the russian and illegal anxion
of the part of
ukraine more specifically the autonomous
republic of crimea and the city of
sebastopol
and
thus
it has violated the fundamental norms of
the international
law
funds
it defends the
norms that guarantee the international
security this is why france has always
supported the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine and
will continue to do so
the
occupation of crimea by russia is a
clear deterioration of the situation
with the human rights
on the territory of the crimea and
we've
seen this and we've mentioned that
during the general assembly of the uan
and
local population suffers because of that
i would like to remind
uh russia of its commitments
compliance with the norms of
international
law
a year ago we've already met to condemn
the annexation of the crimean peninsula
unfortunately
ukraine has selected the path of
diplomacy while russia has selected the
path of war
and once again it has violated the
fundamentals of the international
law and starting its full scale
aggression on the 24th of february
france and the european union as well as
other
allies to ukraine shall
support your struggle your defense
because this is a justice struggle for
your sovereignty with your territorial
integrity and our decisiveness was not
changed we are ready to continue with
our efforts on the long-term perspective
the international community condemned
this aggression
and i would like to say on behalf of all
of our european friends
their friends
from
africa from asia from latin america
what is happening now in ukraine
is not only about the ukrainian people
of course primarily this is the fight of
ukrainian people for its independence
and uh freedom but it's all about all of
us because
we feel the consequences of this war and
it
has to do with
all the other countries it destabilizes
the international norms and rules those
humanitarian consequences
the consequences in terms of energy and
food supplies all of these is the
consequence of the choice made of russia
that is to attack ukraine on the 24th of
february
the war
started by russia is the war
against the very principles of the
international
the law that regulates our relationship
many countries that
have gathered
today that struggled for its own
freedom
decolonization they're here with us
today because
they have protected their own rights
for self-determination what is happening
today is not only a war on the territory
of europe it's all about the universal
principles there is our ability to live
in peace and friendship
with respect to sovereignty territorial
integrity
which are the fundamental main major
values and the principles of the
international
order
which
serve as the preconditions for
guaranteeing the peace russia has made
choice despite its commitments
that they've taken
30 years ago russia has made
his choice to step away from those
principles and we believe this is a
weakness
this is why
i would like to
call upon russia to seize
the military
the actions as and to withdraw
its forces from the territory of ukraine
and to use all forms of diplomacy in
order to protect the ukraine its
territory and its future
recently
that
the war is also about the crime
just as the rest of the ukrainian
territory of the past
six months
and today we've seen a lot of victims
and casualties among the ukrainian
population and i would like to
express words of condolences to the
families of the victims of this
aggression mr president
allow me
once again to
reinforce
my respect
the respect of the people of france
with the struggle with the defense waged
by the people of ukraine every day this
is the fight for your sovereignty your
future your children and this is defined
for our universal principles
[Music]
this is what i wanted to say today in my
statement
through the video conference
today
the future of ukraine is being decided
and we shall stay together with you
today tomorrow the day after tomorrow
but
i wanted to say that this is also a
fight for the principles of
international law
that has to do thank you mr president
case of all of us and our next speaker
is his excellency mario draghi prime
minister of italy
dear president zelinski
dear colleagues
on the second anniversary of the
international crimea platform
i wish to express italy's unwavering
support for this initiative and for
ukraine
russia's occupation of the crimean
peninsula in march 2014
was an unacceptable act of aggression a
clear violation of international law
italy has constantly condemned russia's
illegal annexation of crimea and
moscow's gradual militarization of the
peninsula
we are deeply concerned
for the worsening situation of human
rights in the peninsula
and we stand with the crimean tatar
community against the violence and
injustice it suffers from
the fight for crimea is part of the
struggle to liberate ukraine
last february
russian forces used crimea as a launch
pad for their attack on the regions of
southern ukraine including kersen
they continue to use crimea to put
military pressure on other areas notably
the port cities of mikko life and odessa
as russia attempts to subjugate more
parts of ukrainian territory the
international community cannot look away
russia must stop its illegal occupation
its brutal targeting of unnamed
civilians
italy will continue to support ukraine
we are with you in your fight to resist
russia's invasion restore ukraine's
territorial integrity protect your
democracy and independence thank you
thank you prime minister
our next speaker comes from asia and it
will be the distinguished prime minister
of japan
kishida fumio
[Music]
yes for some technical reasons we will
return to his excellency prime minister
of japan in a couple of minutes and i
will now give the floor to president of
the european council his excellency mr
charles michelle sir the floor is yours
thank you thank you for giving me the
floor
dear president zelinski
their friends excellencies
crimea is ukraine
and i start with the same and clear
message i hated the occasion to convey
last year when i had the occasion to
take part in the first crimea platform
in tf that you initiated the vladimir
the european union does not and will not
recognize the illegal annexation of
crimea and celestial
russian segregation against ukraine
did not start on february 24th it
started in 2014 with the illegalization
of crimea
and this was the beginning of precious
aggressive and unlawful acts against
your country and against your people
this war has caused unspeakable
suffering for millions of ukrainian
families
and since february russia receives
crimea as a strategic springboard to
invade all the parts of ukraine from the
south and to attack ukraine with
indiscriminate missile strikes
russia is also using premier as a
transit point to deport ukrainian
citizens
through in famous filtration camps and
where acts of torture and abuse have
been reported
crimea
has become a transportation hub for
grain stolen from other parts of ukraine
and russia's military presence in crimea
has enforced his blockchain of ukraine
in black steel ports and we have seen
the brutal consequences
damage to the ukrainian economy and
global food security crisis especially
in vulnerable countries let's be clear
this is a deliberate and cynical choice
by the kremlin a deliberate decision to
weaponize hunger and to try to weaken
international support for ukraine and
that's why we welcome the recent green
deal signed in istanbul and the
departure of the first permission ships
from ukraine's black sea ports and we
commend the u.n secretary general's
action to make this deal a reality we
will remain extremely vigilant to make
sure russia implements this deal fully
and in good faith
ladies and gentlemen dear friends we
also want to express our drug concerns
about the repeated challenge at the
laboratory nuclear plant
russia's actions are risky a nuclear
disaster
and this is a moment for caution and
restraint we fully support the efforts
made by secretary general's terrorists
and united nations russia must
immediately give access to young experts
and also support establishing a
demilitarized zone around the nuclear
plants
finally ladies and gentlemen
the vladimir dear friends
the european union has been rock solid
in our support for ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity since 2014
and our support for your countries
unprecedented
we have repeatedly condemned this war in
the strongest possible terms we have
called out racist atrocities against
ukrainian civilians and is demanded that
russia fully respect international
humanitarian law we are also actively
supporting the icc investigation into
war crimes
and have also adopted the most
hard-hitting centers ever against russia
we've also bolstered our already
substantial support to ukraine
with humanitarian aid with
microfinancial resistance with support
for refugees and with unprecedented
military support
we are also committed to ukraine's
bright and prosperous future
and we are ready to play a major role in
international efforts for the
registration of ukraine
their praise zelinski
since march the european council has
clearly stated that ukraine belongs to
our european family
and in june we formally granted
statues
dear european friends and brothers
let me repeat one more time loud and
clear your future lies within the
european union and your bravery is an
example for all of us
and here andre duda i have the same
dream i hope i have also the occasion to
pay a visit
with you vladimir to crimea
the eu is right by your side in these
dramatic times and we will stay there
for as long as it takes
i call on all countries around the world
to clearly condemn russia's immediate
actions
ukraine's full territorial integrity
we've seen its internationally
recognized borders must be restored
crimea east ukraine ukraine east ukraine
you can count on us
thank you
herrem slava mr president
and
the next speaker on my list is her
excellency president's president of the
european commission
ursula van der lion
madam president the floor is yours
president
president duda distinguished guests
in february and march of 2014
russia carried out its annexation of the
crimean peninsula through brutal force
this brazen violation of ukraine's
territorial integrity
and international law
marked the beginning of putin's
deplorable attempt to deny ukraine its
freedom
it was a direct response to ukraine's
revolution of dignity
in which brave ukrainian citizens
demanded justice democracy
and the right to choose their own future
in europe
premier has since then been used not
only as a russian military base
but also as a testing ground for the
brutal methods russia is now applying
across the other occupied parts of
ukraine
you know that the european union is
ukraine's closest friend and a staunch
defender of international law
we will never recognize the illegal
annexation of crimea and sevastopol by
the russian federation
we are deeply concerned about the human
rights violations in the crimean
peninsula the disappearances
the torture
the killings
the persecution of crimean tartars
the intimidation and incarceration of
journalists lawyers and human rights
defenders
this is the dark reality of putin's
occupation
the european union will tirelessly work
with the ukrainian authorities and our
partners
to expose these
violations to hold those responsible
accountable
and to support the victims
we are with you
we have been with you in this
existential fight from the beginning
since russia's full-blown assault in
february we have massively stepped up
our economic humanitarian and military
support
we have welcomed over seven and a half
million ukrainian refugees into our
homes
our sanctions are critically undermining
putin's war machine and the russian
economy
eu solidarity lanes helped export over
10 million tons of ukrainian grain
and we will continue to help you get the
grain out that has been stuck in
ukrainian ports
due to russia's cynical blockade
the european union will continue
to stand with ukraine
for as long as it takes
putin wanted to thwart ukraine's
independence and break your belief in a
better future
the opposite has happened
not only is ukraine celebrating its 31st
year of independence tomorrow
but you have also become
a candidate to join the european union
our people have never been closer
and our commitment to a free and
democratic ukraine
has never been stronger
slava ukrainian
thank you madam president as president
zielenski mentioned in his remarks
we will become members of the european
union together with crimea and crimeans
will be part of europe as
citizens of ukraine
we
have
fixed
technical problems which
allows us to go
back to asia
and to listen to the remarks of his
excellency prime minister of japan
kishida fumio please
subscribe
[Music]
[Music]
thank you prime minister and uh we will
now go to the entire euro-atlantic space
and uh
accordingly invite his excellency
secretary general of nato jans
stoltenberg to take the floor
thank you so much president zielenski
president duda friends of ukraine
eight years ago russia illegally annexed
crimea
transforming it into one of the most
militarized areas in europe
and using it as a launch pad for a
full-scale invasion of ukraine six
months ago
president putin thought he could crush
the ukrainian people and armed forces he
thought he could divide our democratic
nations
and he thought he could dictate what
others do
president putin was wrong
the presence of so many friends of
ukraine here today proves this
ukraine has suffered six terrible months
of war
but you have also shown your incredible
ability to resist brutal aggression
to strike back
retake territory
and impose major costs on russia
nato stands in full solidarity with
ukraine
allies fully support ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
your right to self-defense and to choose
your own path
president putin started this unjustified
war
he must stop this war and withdraw his
forces from ukraine
nato stood with ukraine's sincere
independence
we significantly stepped up our support
after illegal annexation of crimea
when russia invaded again this helped
make the ukrainian armed forces stronger
better trained and better led than in
2014
and since february nato allies have
provided unprecedented military
financial and humanitarian aid
nato is part of the us-led ukraine
defense contact group to mobilize
support
and i actively engage with leaders to
urge them to provide more weapons and
more ammunition more quickly
at our madrid nato summit in june we
agreed a strengthened package of
assistance including fuel food medical
supplies protected military gear
and secure communications as well as
equipment to counter mines drones
chemical and biological threats
and we have over a dozen new projects in
preparation for the winter
at the same time we have strengthened
our presence in the east of the alliance
because nato's security guarantees leave
no room for miscalculation in moscow and
they enable allies
to support ukraine's right to
self-defense
we are committed to our partnership with
ukraine for long term
will help ukraine transition from soviet
era to nato standard equipment
continue your defense and security
sector reform
and help you on the path of post-war
reconstruction
winter is coming
and it will be hard
and what we see now is a grinding war of
attrition
this is a battle of wills
and a battle of logistics
therefore we must sustain our support
for ukraine for the long term
so that ukraine prevails as a sovereign
independent nation
a strong stable and independent ukraine
is essential to your atlantic security
nato has stood with ukraine throughout
three decades of independence
we stand with uk now
we'll continue to stand with ukraine
for as long as it takes
thank you secretary general
now
i would like to take you back
to the last year
when nariman jilal first deputy chairman
of the mentors of the crimean tatar
people took part in the summit
in the first inaugural summit of the
crimea platform
and as president zielinski mentioned in
his introductory remarks upon returning
to crimea mr jalal
had been
taken by the russian security forces
his only connection with the world
from a dark prison
is
letters
and i invite you to watch a short video
with the involvement of his wife livisa
gillard
[Music]
i have slept during the day and now i
cannot sleep i think about to you about
our children i only use so much i know
it's not easy for you but you are next
to them
to our little ones it's difficult to
think that they're growing up without me
especially
she uh
just starting to walk talk and do
something new and funny
i'm afraid that she'll have to get to
know me
once again
is very slow
just one month has passed another month
i feel depressed
that i
try to defend depression
not today though nothing compares to
this
don't you worry
i just need to share this with you
there's nobody else to share it with
you
i'm still confident in you and your
strength
do not be afraid
to be weak
and
we have to
leave we have to
host guests invite friends just remember
that you are the most loved and
one for me and my closest friend no one
is dearer to me than you and our
children
so do everything to make your life full
that will make me stronger and more
confident and i'll fight here this is
the shortest way to you
no
agreements can make this can we
can
they be trusted
we have to fight that's the only way
to fight is the shortest way
to victory